Speaker 1: We have new economic numbers there,
pretty good new weekly jobless claims have
again hit a new pandemic era low.
The Department of Labor once a week releases
these numbers.
They released them this morning.
Initial jobless claims for the week ending
April 10th, meaning last week, came in at
five hundred seventy six thousand new claims.
This is both lower than the 700000 number
that was expected and also the lowest in the
era of the pandemic.
Continuing claims for the week ending, April
3rd, three point seven million.
The basically right on track with what was
expected.
And these are numbers that are likely to continue
improving if we can keep vaccinating quickly.
We've talked about how in some sense the unemployment
numbers are inversely correlated to vaccination.
Of course, there's a whole bunch of other
factors, including local hotspots and state
by state guidelines.
What's going on in Texas is different than
what's going on in the state of Washington
as as two examples.
But if you look at the vaccination docx numbers,
those numbers continue to increase.
We're now up to three point three million
doses per day.
In another 40 days, things could be looking
quite good.
It's quite plausible that by Memorial Day
you will see more states drop mask mandates.
I'm not advocating for or against that.
I'm sort of talking about the the perspective
that I think more and more governors are taking
here.
But short of debating that, for me, the lesson
here, there's probably a few lessons, but
the best lesson here is the best economic
policy.
The best way to protect and shield and recover
the economy during a pandemic has always been
to just deal with the virus.
And what I mean by that is early on in March,
debates about flights and debates about freedom
and debates about masks and closures, quarantines
and the constitutionality of lockdowns and
all of that stuff, there has always been one
path, which is the most the more quickly you
deal with the virus, regardless of the debates
around freedom and constitutionality and whatever,
dealing with the virus most quickly will help
the economy.
And we have examples of it.
New Zealand did an incredible job dealing
with the virus.
They didn't need long debates over whether
to open or closed their mouth.
So they just they did it.
They dealt with it.
And then they had long periods of normality
where much of the rest of the world was very
far from normality.
Israel, in terms of vaccination, Israel was
able to strike a deal early with Pfizer being
a country of only nine million people to get
enough doses for everybody in exchange for
sharing data with Pfizer.
Businesses are open in Israel.
Passover was almost completely normal in Israel
a couple of weeks ago, the entire time the
United States wasted time with conversations
that were being forced upon us by the right,
by the trumpet's, by the anti massacres, by
whoever else.
And all along, the best medical policy was
the best economic policy.
That's what we learned.
And it is increasingly borne out in the data
that we get.
Had we figured out testing earlier, instead
of Trump saying we don't need this slowdown,
testing 15 cases will go to zero.
If we just figured out testing and were able
to contain it, we would have had a problem.
Of course we would have had a problem in a
country of 330 million people, but it wouldn't
have gotten as bad as it did.
The economy would have gotten better more
quickly.
Had we had competent leadership early, the
economy would have done better all along.
Other good indicators economically, by the
way, retail sales up about nine percent higher
in March.
That is significant.
A lot of it is coming from bars and restaurants
and other business areas.
And then the result of all of this is the
stock market popping today, all time highs.
You're not seeing Joe Biden tweet endlessly
about it, but the Dow Jones Industrial Average
was up more than 200 points as of when I looked
at it half an hour ago, hit an all time high.
The S&P 500 hitting an intraday record forever.
The forever record was hit today.
Nasdaq up one percent.
Of course, the economy is not the stock market,
but the point is all of it together confirms
that the better we do against the virus.
That's the economic policy.
It's not the debate between public health
policy and economic policy.
It's all the same.
The economy does better.
When we better deal with the virus, we better
deal with the virus.
When we understand that we don't need to think
about the virus as.
Separate and distinct from the economy, because
it all goes hand in hand, we'll hope for continued
improvement in the numbers.
My belief is and again, I always make very
clear, I'm not coming up with this stuff on
my own.
I'm looking at the public health experts because
they are the experts.
It seems as though 40 days from now, numbers
will look significantly better and hopefully
as a result, economic numbers will.
As well